it's one of the biggest storms ever to
hit America in its strength and scale
hurricane Ian didn't spare the Sunshine
State
this category 4 hurricane measured more
than 30 miles wide the damage at left
should its devastating power
this had been a Causeway linking Sanibel
Island with the Florida Mainland no
longer
millions of people Statewide were caught
up in the danger posed by 150 mile an
hour winds and so-called Storm surges of
water as high as 12 feet
[Music]
the town of Naples was caught in the
Hurricane's cross Hills as they cleaned
up here they recalled a Night Under
Siege the guys are pushing the truck out
of the bay this had been the scene at
the town's fire station at the height of
the hurricane the building itself was
flooded leaving one fire Appliance out
of action the water came up fast and I
think it started to affect the
electrical system the chief showed us
the damage and shared his despair I have
33 years on the job and to not be able
to go and help when we're called just
eats at you as the hurricane blew on
elsewhere the number of confirmed
fatalities left in its wake grew the
amount of water that's been rising and
will likely continue to rise today even
as The Storm Is Passing is basically a
500 year flood event in Florida more
than 2 million people were left without
power it was coming through the doors
and but and up through the floor it did
as fast as we could do anything so then
finally we had to go upstairs are you
getting on my gutius lives in a beach
house a hundred years old it's a loss
and the other house you know
electricity's been messed with old
wooden floors have been soaking up water
so it's not a good situation
with this hurricane is a rip through
this state was the pace at which it
moved it was slow and so it caused
damage over an extended period it's also
prevented rescue teams from taking to
the road and reaching people in danger
in Naples they've been recording these
historic scenes tourists in their own
time the landmark Pier Bears the scars
of hurricane Ian across this town and
this state it has been a tough ride
James Matthews Sky News Florida